the Marvel Cinematic Universe will soon
have a new captain but it won't be Steve
Rogers best pal Bucky bounce and
Sebastian Stanley has portrayed Bucky in
the MCU since 2011 Captain America the
First Avenger has revealed the reason
why the actors spoke with the Hollywood
reports are about the evolution of his
character and opened up about white
Steve Rogers chose to give his shield to
Sam Wilson rather than to Bucky at the
conclusion of Avengers endgame for
context suppose summoned Bucky have done
the Captain America moniker and the
Marvel Comics and many felt Bucky was
more deserving than Sam to receive the
shield within the MCU when Sam was
presented with cap shield he was a first
reluctant to take it but a solemn and
approving nod from Bucky was all it took
to clue the audience in to the fact that
the Winter Soldier knew Steve had made
the right choice in his chat with thr
Stan gave his take on the moments and
also clarified a plot point the fans
have scrubbed over since end games
release Steve didn't just want a normal
life for himself he wanted one for Bucky
to kiss him with you
[Music]
Burkean Sam might have been caps two
best buddies but only Bucky knew what it
was like to be a man out of his time
displaced from the era in which he
belonged been to the will of others and
forcin to the exact opposite of a normal
existence stan explained to THR that cap
understood Bucky had also lost anything
resembling the life he might have had
when he was rescued from certain death
and engineered by Hydra to be a perfect
ageless weapon as Stan tells it that was
at least partially the reason Steve gave
the shield to Sam instead of his oldest
friend he didn't want to burden Bucky
with it
he explained well we arrived with Bucky
at the end felt more like he was in a
play to the desire for some sort of
release to start over start life or
getting away find out who he is again on
his own and leave all this behind
so what felt like a desire there was for
a restart for him and for Steven away it
didn't necessarily feel like the shield
was gonna be that Stan went on to
explain that in not handing Bucky the
shield Steve was suggesting that Bucky
too could have a do-over he said Steve
is saying to Bucky you're going to go
and live a normal life - I'm not going
to put this thing on you so that's her I
thought they were at the end of the
movie
I didn't think there's a desire or any
conflicting thoughts about taking on
that mantle
some to me was always a clear man to
take on that mantle for numerous reasons
fans have always been a bit confused
about Bucky's apparent lack of surprise
when Steve failed to return after
blasting off into the past were the
Infinity stones but as far as Stan is
concerned it was pretty much a given
that but he knew exactly what caps plan
was the actor said that scene was saying
so much of subtext it's just a knowledge
that these guys have always known each
other's moves so to speak they knew each
other so well that they could say okay I
know what he's going to do what
decisions he's going to make and I
support this yeah it's just what it was
Stan went on to clarify that he played
the final scene before cap goes back in
time as a goodbye and then suggested
that buck he didn't say anything for one
simple reason I know he's going and he's
not going to come back I can't talk
about it because if I do then they're
going to try and stop him from doing
what he wants to do upon me watching the
scene this is all pretty clear yes Stan
is greater understanding emotions and
then the Sun that his character is a man
of few words you explain look I love a
good scene with dialogue but sometimes I
find it really interesting when there's
not a lot said gun funnily enough its
source of being the trademark of Bucky
Marvel lights can see Bucky and Sam the
new owner of the Captain America shield
in action when the Falcon and the
winter soldier premieres on Disney Plus
later in 2020 check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]